you have to make money doing this so
that you can make this your full-time
thing so you can hire a team so you can
expand so you can have a bigger reach so
you can have a a much bigger impact so
you can actually create the world that
you want to create again money is not
number one but you have to figure out a
way to make money so inside of your big
dream what is the next step that you
have to take that's going to start to
get you paid and often it's coaching
often it's selling your time often it's
taking the expertise that you have have
inside you you solved the problem for
yourself now you're going to help other
people do it you're going to get paid to
do it